hello everyone this next game I'm about
to show you was played in a very strong
tournament in Zurich in 1959 Bobby
Fischer was playing Paul Karras and body
was 16 years old at the time and he came
like this close to winning the
tournament but he lost the geller before
before the last round and I was a pretty
hard blow for him but he also he still
had a chance to win the tournament as he
faced mikhail tal in the last round but
he didn't manage to achieve a victory
against all so they drew the game and
india and Michael Dell won the
tournament which was second and Bobby
shared the third place with Paul Karras
and that's exactly the game I want to
show you Bobby Fischer versus Paul
carrot as this is Bobby's first victory
against a Russian Grand Master I think
prior to this game he played four games
against the Russian Grand Masters and
all game all four games were drawn so
this is the game against Paul carries
the Bobby is Weis and chaos is black the
the opening moves are real opus so we're
not going to analyze those a six we
should pick for Knight f6 Fischer
castles Bishop d7 root 3/1 b5 Bishop to
b3 b6 c3 black castles h3 Knight to a5
Bishop dusty to c5 and LD for Queen to
c7 night B D to C takes D for C takes D
for Bishop to be 792 F 1 R ok to c8
Bishop to d3 Knight to c6 and now Knight
the e3 and here before this move when
chaos blade Knight to c6 is actually
attacking the d4 pawn but the Fischer
plays Knight to the e3 with the idea of
sacrificing this point but if you like
captures
Fisher will put his knight on f5 and
Fisher understand positionally that if
he if he manages to exchange his a nice
for this dark square Bishop on e7 then
his Bishop Bishop pair will be far
superior and caris understand this as
well so he plays rook to e8 making room
for his Bishop on f8 so please replace
Knight to f5 and caris plays Bishop to
f8 but now Bobby still isn't interested
in this d4 pawn and he plays Bishop to
g5 and this is a very unpleasant new for
black as the night can't really be
defended and caris doesn't want to play
Bishop days back d7 because that's like
admitting the whole route to e8 Bishop
the FS idea was was a mistake so Karis
just moves the knight Knight to d7 and
Fischer plays rook to see what a nice
developmental move he's a dead queen
room c7 also making the room for is the
light square Bishop to retreat and b1
and his position is looking very nice
still carries can't capture the pawn on
d4 she plays the Queen to be a time
painting the Queen and our Bishop
purpose is Bishop back to Bishop to be
one and now Karis finally captures the
pawn and this is what I really like
about Fischer Fischer's games although
he was just 16 years old here he really
understood chests on a positional level
which you'll see right now Karis plate
and might I say Karis was an extremely
strong player to beat he was at the time
cameras was considered the strongest
player who never became world champion
so he took a knight takes on d4 and
Fisher captures with the f3 Knight nice
capture Sun before and here is a move in
between rook takes on c1 and Fischer
places we should stay
see one and this is a also a very nice
move because the bishop wasn't really
doing anything at g5 and now he's also
making this with the g4 move really
unpleasant for black so he takes b4
recapturing the knife and you can see
that black is a pawn up but his pawn
structure is all messed up and this is
what the Fisher gets in return even more
compensation plays Knight to h6
temporarily sacrificing tonight
Black has to capture because he will
lose the polymer 7 so Karis has to take
the nice G takes on h6 and now Queen to
g4 check King to h8 and now Queen takes
27 and Fischer is still down upon but
look at the pawn structure you can see
Fischer has a very nice pawn structure
he has only two points here and here and
the Charis is contractor is all messed
up he goes for point islands and these
2.0 and says double phone so Harris
plays Bishop to b5 protecting with the
tactics because the the rock only one is
pinned now the bishop can be taken
Fischer plays Queen to f5 attacking the
bishop and now worked 85 Queen to f3 and
now f5 really going for that efore point
Fischer calmly plays Bishop to s4
attacking the rook rook goes back to e8
and Fischer plays Queen to h5 offering
another point but the pawn cannot be
taken with ethics on e4 because the
bishop is hanging so Fisher is making
carriers captured upon with a piece so
Karis obliges Bishop takes on e4 and now
f3 and now the rook is pinned from the
Queen and rook and the only way to
defend the rook is to play Bishop to c6
so here is Bishop to c6 and our Fischer
Moses rook to this C file
which will be a very important file as
you'll see Bishop to d7 facial captures
mh6
[ __ ] rook attacks the bishop on h6
Bishop takes on a faced queen takes on f
8 and up into h4 attacking this doubled
pawn here on d4 and it's not very easy
to defend this pawn so Karis has to play
Queen to f6 and exchange Queens and fish
were happily does it Queen takes on f6
or takes on f6 and look at the position
now it's a both players have rooks and a
light squared bishop and curses upon up
but fish respond structure is so much
better and fishery is controlling this C
file which will prove deadly akin to F 2
into G 7 and now already we can see
demons influence this rook has on this
e-file there's there's even a saying in
chess that you should always put a rock
on your ears always put a rock on an
open file even if it cost you the game
because if you don't it probably will
cause to the game so look the seventh
King TV to f4
this was probably a poor judgment move
by Karis as it allows this bishop to
have this great diagonal and maybe maybe
some tactical threat to this h7 pawn
we're up to 87 King to f6
rook grab the pawn of the the material
is equal roughly 7 checked into f2
Bishop to e6 Fischer grabs another pawn
king to e5 rip the c6 Bishop to b5
attacking the rook rook to h6 rook the
c7 now Karis is controlling the C file
but it doesn't really matter
rook to h5 checks King to d6 rook j6
check some repetition moves maybe maybe
together maybe to get the
control came back 35 rock to h5 check
kink the d6 and our Fisher find this
rope Delphi move rope to see one Bishop
to d3 rope the D 1 in 32 and now
attacking the pawn and G 2 came back to
s 2 another repetition of moves rip the
d1 King to e 2 root 2 G 1 and now rope
the g5 Fischer finds a way to continue
Bishop captures the pawn and a - and now
the material is again equal but Fischer
captures Bishop takes on d5 rope to be 1
K 2 D 3 8 6 root 2 H 5 rope characters
on b2 now again the material is equal
but special characters can take some d4
rook takes on g2 and our takes on 86
checks in 3 7 and now root 3 4 and this
is a very tricky position because
although Weiss is the pawn up you can
see that black if the ribs are exchanged
and black can sacrifice this Bishop for
this f3 pawn and then why can no longer
win because he has a bad bishop he can't
Queen his pawn and a dark square with a
light squared bishop so carries knows
this and careful so I very hard to do
this rook to g5 Bishop to a6 the ship to
s7 Bishop to c8r up to g6 trying to
exchange a rock rock to h7 into a fate
Bishop to g4 and now again trying to
exchange rooks rod c6 there are update 6
up to g6 and now Fischer probably
calculated that the position is 1 so he
takes the pawn bishop to g6 and King
takes on f4 and now the only thing
Fischer has to do to win this game is
the stop black from somehow sacrificing
this bishop
for this f3 pawn against the g8 is g7
picking the g5 Bishop Pro goes to d3 at
4 so the danger is out of the way
Bishop to e4 h for Bishop to b3 e h5
Bishop a4 a6 check King to h8 and now
Bishop to f5 black can't really capture
the bishop so Bishop to b5 Bishop to g6
Bishop to e6 into f6 Bishop to c4 came
back to g5 Bishop to e6 Bishop to h5
into h7 trying to exchange Bishop to g4
Bishop goes back to c4 and only now he
pushes f5 Bishop goes the f7 Bishop to
h5 Bishop to c4 check the g8 and now f6
and in this position
carousel finally resigned there is a
fourth win here of Zweifel simply
maneuver his King around and he will he
will manipulate this black Bishop to to
move out of the way so white will easily
win this so yeah this is a this is what
I really like about Fischer's games he
really understands he really understands
the positions and he knew that the
bishops
would be stronger there and that gave me
the opportunity to sacrifice that pawn
and well he calculated everything and he
won the game and he didn't win the
tournament as he said a two-bed games in
the ending although ok he did draw with
a michael town in the last round but
yeah this is this is how Bobby achieved
his first victory against the Russian
Grand Master and yeah what a what a
victory it was he he himself and the
tournament committee said that this was
definitely his best game and that for
sixteen-year-old to play such positional
chess against grandmaster like paul
cares that it's well the there surely is
much more to expect from expect from
this sixteen-year-old in the future yeah
so that the game i hope you enjoyed it
and I'll see you soon